[Musique]
ça c'est un paquet pour vous et pour moi
bonjour monsieur gré vous trouverez la
tondeuse stensness style advance pour
l'attester ainsi qu'une lithium-ion pour
le jeu concours bon test et à bientôt
clos et merci claude avant de l'essayer
je vais vous offrir celle là pour la
gagne et c'est super simple vous vous
abonner à la chaîne vous commentez en
expliquant pourquoi vous devriez la
gagner vous mettez un pouce bleu sur la
vidéo et vous invitez tous vos amis
d'ici quelques jours je vous dirai qui a
gagné pas mal on va l'essayer tout de
suite
[Musique]
dans quelques heures on passe en 2017 et
je voulais en profiter pour faire un
petit récap de 2016 alors j'espère que
vous avez passé une bonne année ça s'est
plutôt bien passé que vous avez tenus
vos bonnes résolutions et que tous les
voeux vous avez formulées en début
d'année ont été exaucés 2007 c'était
quand même une année en demi-teinte
forcément une année qui commence par la
mort de michel delpech et david bowie
docs ou simplement un petit peu quand
dans la foulée vous enchaînez avec
boutros ghali prince mohammed ali sonia
rykiel leonard cohen carrie fisher
george michael
là c'est un petit peu l'hécatombe on
peut même féliciter tous ceux qui ont
survécu à 2016 parce que franchement
survivre à 2016 c'était pas évident en
attendant fin 2016 j'ai lancé le blog
pour début 2010 est je vous réserve un
paquet de surprise on va avoir plein
plein de choses à voir ensemble plein de
surprises plaint d' aventure pleine de
nouveautés j'espère que vous avez passé
un excellent réveillon à ce que moment
où vous regardez cette vidéo forcément
on sera le 1er janvier
donc je me permets de vous souhaiter une
excellente année 2010 est tous mes voeux
de bonheur j'espère vous allez vous
accomplir de faire tout ce que vous
voulez je vous souhaite de la joie de
l'amour de l'amour de l'amour de la joie
de l'argent la santé et tout ce que vous
voudrez restez connectés par ce que je
vous dis en 2017 il va y avoir
énormément de surprises
baba qu'elle est venue bienvenus ça va
péter mackay du nouvel an ce formidable
magnifique importe quoi google a pas que
ça qui est pleine
la louve est à moi c'est pas grave
[Musique]
nous avons
jamais
[Musique]